字幕: Qun Dai
校正: Kumika Moore
今日すごくいい天気でしたね
今から僕は「てんき」の話をしていきます
「てんき」と言っても
こっちの「転機」
人生の転機の話
たぶん皆さんもこれまで
何度か人生の転機を経験されてると思います
でも自分の人生の転機って
意外と少ないんですね
僕たち自分の人生の転機よりも
他人の人生の転機と関わる回数の方が
圧倒的に多いんです
例えば子供の入学や卒業
友達の引っ越しや同僚の結婚など
なので今日僕は実際に携わった
２人の人生の転機を紹介しながら
「他人の人生の転機」との関わり方について
話をしていきます
まず１人目は
MEG（めぐ）
僕が彼女に会った当時
彼女は大学で栄養士になるための
勉強をしていました
順調に栄養士の資格を取得して
大学を卒業し 就職をして働き始めます
ただ働き始めて３ヶ月が経った頃に
相談のメールが来ました
「お仕事の事で少し相談したいんですが
お時間ありますか？」と
僕はすぐに時間を空けて
彼女と会うことにしました
そこで彼女が話していた内容を
ざっとまとめると こんな感じです
「就職をしたら想像と違った」
「今の仕事は やりたいことじゃない」
「辞めた後どうしたらいいか わからない」と
そんなに珍しい悩みじゃないですよね？
たぶんこの中にも
同じような悩みを相談された方や
今同じ悩み抱えてる方もいるかもしれません
さて どうしましょう？
当時の彼女の様子だと
それ以上同じ仕事続けるのは
少し精神的に無理だろうなという感じでした
もう少し深く話を聞いていくと
明らかにですね
彼女の表情が明るくなる瞬間があるんですね
それはカメラの話をしてる時でした
聞けば親戚に買ってもらったデジカメで
毎日自分が撮ったご飯の写真を撮っている と
しかも好きな写真は永遠に見ていられるし
カメラの事はどれだけ考えても飽きない
そんなに好きなんだったら
カメラを仕事にしてしまおう と
ただ当時 彼女は一眼レフカメラすら
持ってなかったので
僕が持っていたカメラをプレゼントしました
そして 約束をして
「毎日最高の写真を撮り続けよう」と
具体的に言うと
彼女が１日かけて撮影したたくさんの写真から
ベストの１枚を僕に送ってきます
僕はその写真に対して
具体的なフィードバックをして
ウェブに毎日１枚ずつ公開していく
この作業を僕たち２人は100日間続けました
100日間毎日続けると
いろいろ見えてきますね
特に彼女の場合 明らかにわかってきたのは
気持ちの乗る写真と乗らない写真が
すごくはっきりしてるんです
これは当時彼女が撮影した写真なんですが
この食や人をテーマにした写真
これはものすごくいい写真を撮るんです
でも一方 風景や建物をテーマにした写真
これは僕の心にあまり響かなかったんですね
ただ これ僕だけじゃなくて
撮影してる彼女自身も
全く同じことを感じていました
なので この時点で苦手な写真は捨てて
得意な食と人の写真だけで
勝負をしていこうと決めました
ただ「プロとしてやっていくなら
好き嫌いなんか言ってちゃ
ダメなんじゃない？」と
思う方もいるかもしれませんが
僕は本当に好きなこと１つ
極めることができたら
プロとして十分やっていけると考えてます
特にそれがその人の時間
人生の時間すべてを費やせるほど好きである
没頭できるものである場合
その可能性は圧倒的に高いと思います
彼女にとって写真は
すべての時間を費やせるものでした
そして100日の取り組みが終わる頃には
彼女のオリジナルの撮影スタイルが
完成したんです
皆さん 家族の写真って思い浮かびます？
おうちの中で撮った写真って
ほとんどお父さんかお母さんが撮るので
子供ばっかり写ってるんですね
一方 外で撮った写真は
行事や記念日がすごく多いので
少し着飾った写真が多いんです
でも本当に残したい家族の姿って
子供を見つめるお母さんの
この自然なまなざしだったり
つまみ食いをしてるところだったり
家族で食卓を囲んでるこんな当たり前の
風景なんじゃないかと思うんです
フォトグラファーのMEGが
自宅に実際にお邪魔をして
その家庭の当たり前の日常を記録に残す
「食卓写真」というプロジェクトが
誕生しました
たくさんの家庭の撮影をさせていただく中で
こちらのご家族から撮影の半年後に
お手紙をいただきました
「先月 母が病気で亡くなりました
あの時の写真はまさに
母と私たちが一緒に過ごした日常の証で
きっとこの先もずっと母との思い出を
鮮明によみがえらせてくれることと思います
病気が発覚し
もう限られた時間しか過ごせないと
わかった時にすぐ
あの時撮影してもらって
本当によかったと思いました
改めてありがとう」
この手紙を受け取って
僕とMEGは「食卓写真」を始めた意味が
あったなぁと感じました
それから２年が経ち
MEGは今 日本各地に加えて
海外からも声がかかる
フォトグラファーになりました
そして２人目は
くどうまさき
僕が出会った当時 彼は
鍼治療の専門学校に通ってました
出会いのきっかけは
僕が開催した体のワークショップに
彼が参加したくれたことが
始まりだったんですが
彼は友達に連れてこられただけで
全然乗り気じゃなかったんですね
なので ワークショップ自体は
半年続くすごく長いものだったんですが
最初の方 彼
全然口を利いてくれなかったんです
それがですね
出会って２ヶ月もする頃に
２人きりで食事をすることになりました
その時のこと今でもはっきり覚えてます
注文した食事が運ばれてきて
僕が食べようとしたら
珍しく彼の方から口を開いたんですね
何と言ったと思います？
「僕 堂嶋さんのこと苦手です！！」
って言ったんですよ
普通 目の前の相手に言わないですよね
こういうこと
ただ 彼はこうやって本音を
初めて打ち明けてくれたところから
僕と彼の距離は一気に近くなりました
それからいろんな話をしていくと
実は彼は口下手なだけで
ものすごく物事をよく観察しているし
深く考えている と
なので もしかしたら彼は
ぴったりな表現方法１つ見つかったら
ものすごい面白い人間になるじゃないかと
そう感じたんです
とはいえ いきなり「君には表現力が
足りないから これをやりなさい」と
言われたところで人は やらないですよね？
たぶんこういう時は
その人の興味あるところから攻めていくと
うまくいく気がします
当時の彼の好奇心がもっとも
刺激されるキーワードは「アフリカ」でした
じゃあ アフリカ人に会いに行こう と
ちょうどそのタイミングで
世界中のボーイスカウトの子供達が
集まる「世界ジャンボリー」というイベントが
日本で開催されることを知りました
そこには約３万人を超える
世界中の子供が集まります
しかも鍼灸師のボランティアスタッフを
募集していたんです
完璧なタイミングでした
僕と くどうくんはすぐに応募をして
１週間 世界各地から来た子供たちに
針とお灸をしました
ここでの体験は本当に
素晴らしいものだったんですが
それ以上に最高の出会いがありました
それは一緒にボランティアスタッフとして
参加した鍼灸師のメンバーです
ボランティアといっても
それぞれが世界各国で開業して
日本に帰ってきたような
日本人鍼灸師の
オールスターのような人々でした
日中のボランティアは彼らと一緒に
世界中の子供達に針やお灸をして
夜はみんなでご飯を食べます
その時に世界中の話をしてくれるんですね
僕もすごくテンションが上がりました
もちろん くどうくんもどんどん
テンションが上がってきて
珍しく自分から夢を語り出したんです
「僕は30歳になったら
必ずアフリカに行きたいんです」と
たぶん くどうくんは
「若いのに すごいね」って言葉を
期待したと思うんですよ
でも経験積んでる人は甘くなかったですね
彼が「30歳になったら
アフリカに行きたいんです」って言ったら
「なんで来年行かないの？」と
「なに先伸ばしにしてんの？」と
彼を怒られ始めたんですね
そして怒られて追い詰められた彼は
もう その場で宣言をさせられました
「来年の誕生日に僕はアフリカに行きます」と
理由はどうあれ 人間はやっぱり
決めると強いですね
彼は本当に宣言通り 翌年の誕生日に
アフリカのケニアに旅立ちました
そして ケニヤでは たくさん友達作って
ボランティアでマッサージして
海外での初めての生活を
すごく楽しんでたみたいです
ところがですね
ある日 街のATMでお金を下ろして
外に出たら
知らないアフリカ人４人組に手足担がれて
車で連れ去られたんですね
くどうくん誘拐されました
（笑）
そのまま知らないところ連れてかれて
あり金 全部取られて
でも何も抵抗しなかったらしいので
無事だったらしいんですよ
怖いですよね 本当に
ただその出来事が彼の人生に
ものすごく大きい影響を与えたんです
彼そこからお金がもうないので
貧しい村に寝泊まりしてたらしいです
そこでは雨水を飲むような暮らしを
していたらしいんですが
そこで出会ったこの子供達
彼らの笑顔が本当に眩しかったみたいで
ただ村が貧しすぎるので 衛生状態が悪い
なので この子供達が毎年どんどん
どんどん病気で亡くなるらしいんですね
彼は生まれて初めて
子供が大人になることすらできないという
環境を目の当たりにしました
そこで自分は今 何ができるんだろうと
考え始めたんです
今もまだ その答えは見つかってません
でも彼はこれからは自分の手で
その答えを見つけていくと思います
日本に帰ってきた くどうくんは
本当にたくましい人間になってました
当時から考えられないくらい堂々と
コミュニケーション取りますし
もう僕のこと苦手じゃないらしいです
（笑）
そんな彼はですね
今 何をやってるかというと
外国で針を刺したり
グアテマラの湖でジャンプしたり
渋谷で馬の散歩をしています
いったい何をやってるんだろうと
思うかもしれませんが 確実に言えるのは
彼の人生は今
めちゃくちゃ楽しそうだってことです
これすごく大事なことだと思います
ここまで２人の人生の転機を
紹介してきましたが
おそらく皆さんも これからたくさんの人の
人生の転機と関わると思うんです
なので その時に役立ちそうなポイント
３つ簡単にまとめました
１つ目は
「前兆に気付く」
前兆というのは変化が起こる前の
小さな変化のことを言います
前兆は 仕草や言葉や環境
様々なところに現れます
ただ この前兆だけを見つけるというのは
すごく難しいです
なぜなら変化というのは
変化する前の状態と後の状態
これを比較して初めてわかるからです
なので 前兆に気付くために大切なのは
その人の日常をよく知ること
その人が普段どんなことをして
何を考えてるのか
これをしっかり観察していれば
少しの変化に気づくことができます
人生の転機の前には必ず前兆が存在します
２つ目
「道筋に灯をともす」
人は遠くにある憧れや目標は
すごく眩しく見えるんです
でもそこまでの行き方がわからないから
どうしても１歩目を踏み出せません
だったら その道筋を僕らが
照らしてあげたらいいと思います
例えばMEGの場合
毎日送ってくる写真に対して
具体的なフィードバックすることで
１歩ずつ前に進めました
くどうくんの場合は
世界の入り口まで連れていったら
それからは もう１人で自由に歩き出しました
決して背中を押し続けるわけではありません
僕たちは たまたま人生で ―
今日もそうです
人生の途中で
たまたま出会っただけなんです
なので最後まで一緒に
歩き続けるわけではありません
いつか別れるということを前提に
彼らの道筋に灯をともします
最後３つ目は
「理由を作る」
自分の変化したいという気持ちに気づいて
目の前の道が照らされたとしても
それでもまだ１歩を踏み出せない人は
たくさんいます
だったら理由を作っちゃいましょう
でも それは世界平和みたいな
そんな大袈裟な理由じゃなくていいと思います
MEGみたいに 写真が好きだという
強い思いから始まることもあれば
くどうくんみたいに
無理やり言わされた日にちが
理由になるということもありえます
それでも１歩目踏み出すの怖かったら
１歩目で失敗しても大丈夫なんですよ
２歩目で修正すれば
２歩目で失敗したら
３歩目で修正すれば大丈夫
もし全く理由が見つかんないんだとしたら
あなたが理由になってあげてください
たぶん皆さんも あの人がいたから
頑張れたっていうことあると思うんですよ
誰かにとっての「あの人」は
あなたかもしれません
最後になりますが
僕の本業 仕事は治療家です
病気や怪我を治すのが仕事なんですね
なので 写真やアフリカは
本当は関係ないんですよ
なのに なんで僕は
わざわざ自分から首を突っ込んで
こんなことやってるんだろうと
改めて考えました
考えてわかったのはですね
僕はただ彼らの成長を見て
ニヤニヤしたいんですね
（笑）
もちろん みんなが
偉大な人物になってくれたら
それはすごく嬉しいことなんですけど
普通の のんびりした人生も
僕は なかなかいいと思うんですよ
なので それぞれが
自分らしい生き方を見つけてくれたら
最高かなと思ってます
それに 自分から首突っ込むことで
僕自身の人生が豊かになってることは確かです
いやぁ 今日は本当にいいてんきでしたね
ありがとうございました
（拍手）